what about the ground predictions here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club with 35 grand on
the line 20 international chess
professionals compete in st. Louis as US
chess champs calm presents the first
ever summer chess classic
[Music]
hello everyone welcome to this Central's
chest up studio in the 2018 summer test
classic I am women Grandmaster Catarina
named Tova and I am here with
international master Eric Rosen because
summer is classic is part of the Chess
Club seasonal classic series featuring
strong players ready 25 to 2600 from all
over the world we will see some familiar
but also some new faces Eric what's what
an exciting event ahead of us yeah I'm
really looking forward to it very very
strong event we have two sections filled
with grandmasters and it's the first
time that the summer classic is being
run at the st. Louis chess club and it's
not even summer time it's still spring I
also feel the Chess Club wants to be
ahead of thing that's true but but the
weather is warm enough for summer so
without further ado let's get into the
player rosters for group a we have
Jeffrey Zhang leading the pack rated 26
61 feet a and we have Alexander in judge
closing out the pack rated 2600 few days
so we have a very close range of players
where really anyone can be in contention
for first place and look at a federation
I mean we have players from the United
States from Netherlands Germany
Kazakhstan Hungary Serbia I mean it's a
so exciting field that's right do you
have any picks for who you think will
will take the money home I think this is
so difficult to make especially before
any result is done I would maybe go with
various go beyond I think he played
really great US Championship although
the finish maybe was not that great I
think now he is relaxed and do his best
yeah Boris a good pick I mean he had a
kind of a rough finish to the US
Championships but very strong starts I
think for him it's a lot about
consistency but my pick for the
tournament is Jeffrey Zhang I mean he's
he's been around for many years now I
first saw him at the st. Louis chess
club when he was just a tiny little
person and now he's grandmaster top
hundred in the world and I know he's
devoting a lot of energy to improving
his game further so let's move on to the
the roster for Group B where we have
another very strong field of players
ranging from just under twenty six
hundred feet a we have Camille dragon
raid
twenty-five ninety-one leading the pack
rounding out the pack we have Tata if
Audrey honey and 23:54 fides she's fresh
off finishing the US Women's
Championship any pics Karina
I'm really happy first of all to see in
this field some female players and also
in this view there are so many college
players we have represented utrgv by
andreas to poki and brother in Bellas we
have the coach of slow I think this is a
great event and my pick let's go with
the first one with calendar a good not a
bad pick and we should note that a lot
of the the collegiate players have just
finished their semesters at university I
was actually playing a few blitz games
with Sergey Mott Cinco last night and he
was saying he finished his semester a
couple days ago and I don't know if he
wants me saying this but I don't think
he had too much time to prepare for this
event so let's look now at a tournament
format so tournament format we have 210
player round-robin groups with a time
control of 90 minutes for 40 moves plus
30 minutes for the remainder of the game
and throughout the game we have a
30-second increments you know what that
means games can last a long long time we
can expect a lot of fighting because
also the players are not allowed to
agree on any draw before move 30 so not
only the games will be long but
hopefully there will be a lot of fights
what do you think Eric that's right and
I mean games can last what five six
hours and it takes a lot of physical and
mental stamina for an event like that
like this and it's it's nine straight
days of chess there's no rest days so we
should we should take a look at the
schedule for the event we have games
every day starting at 1:00 p.m. at st.
Louis time central time zone with the
last day the game starts two hours
earlier at 11:00 a.m. and I mean we're
all hoping for a playoff that that would
be really exciting to see if that
happens it will take place 5:00 p.m. on
Wednesday the 23rd so we are on air
every day at 3:30 so now let's look at
the games that are currently being
played
that's right and we have pairings for
group group a which the round started
about two and a half hours ago
we have yarrow jariabek playing against
Benjamin Bach Sam seven against Peter
Prohaska Daniel Freedman against Wasif
Terra Bailey Alexander in Jets against
version of Cobian and Jeffrey Zhong
against Renata mabye of and I think for
today our game of the day is Jeffrey
Zhong against Rinat Juma by of where we
have the strongest average rating out of
any game in the field this game I am
reena Juma boy it's a completely new
name new face I've never heard never
seen this player before what about you
Eric yeah I'm only familiar with Jeffrey
who I've known for many years I
I mean I'm rooting for Jeffrey as as the
American player but we have to do that I
mean Renacci Aliyev is over 2,600 feet a
and I mean he has to be somewhat decent
at chess right absolutely so now let's
look at the pairings for a group B so we
have camel dragoon against dinara Sidhu
a cassava Tata Abraham Ian against
Sergei mishchenko Josh Friedel against
Alejandro Ramirez Renaud and Kazarian
against Andre superconn and Valentino
bellows against Ali morandi what do you
think is the key match of the day I mean
the game that I'm looking most forward
to is the one between Josh Vidal and
Alejandro Mira's the two American
players in Group B personally I know I
know both of them very well
Josh Vidal we went shopping last night
with a very very good chef it's probably
out of all the GM's in the world he
probably makes the best eggs benedict
and Alejandra Ramirez fresh off doing
Spanish commentary for the US
Championships so he's been involved with
a lot of high-level chests and he's also
the coach of the st. Louis University
chess team so I know he puts a lot of
effort into coaching elite EMS and puts
a lot of effort into opening preparation
so we don't introduce those really
strong players from all over the world
they will be fighting hard so let's see
what they are fighting for what is the
prize fund for group a so it's 22,000 in
total
Eric how do you feel about this
I kind of wish I was playing the event
rather than being a commentator it's a
very generous prize fund with six
thousand dollars for first prize tenth
place is still a very hefty thousand
bucks so I'm sure the players are taking
this very seriously
and they're gonna be fighting for every
game and the groobie it has also a very
nice price fund the total is fourteen
hundred here 14,000 14,000 I'm sorry
with a four thousand dollar first-place
prize $500 for 10th place that can buy a
lot of a lot of Starbucks and a lot of
retainers so it should be an exciting
event absolutely so let's look at a key
matchup of the day for a group a so yeah
let's start with the game between Jeffry
and Gina Juma buyeth where it it began
as a very kind of dry symmetrical
opening if we forget there if we go back
to see how this position happened it
started off as an exchange love which is
probably one of the most boring openings
and chests and we were looking at this
game earlier and we're thinking like
okay this is the day of this is the game
of the day but it may not be that
interesting but let's look what happen
there yeah I want to zoom through the
opening because okay both players
develop their pieces nothing too much
eventful and then at some point the
position just exploded after a queen c3
Knight c4 let's go forward a bit further
after 96 black Soloff was a bit awkward
after Knight c5 the Knights got traded
the pawns to the pawn structure became a
bit less symmetrical and after 94 or
naive for Queen d4 rook a 8 and b4 it
seems like White has a really nice pole
in this position very stable pawn on c5
supported by the b-pawn box bishop bit
passive on on e7 and if we go forward
even further if I can stop you here
let's look at a knight on e4 I mean
that's an amazing piece but the knight
actually started on being on c6 and
having nowhere to go and that's really
interesting maneuver how Renaud got the
Knight to e4 that is true and it's
probably one of the best pieces for luck
in the game so we'll have to see if
white can manage
play around the night or somehow somehow
trade off the night but it is it is a
strong point for black in the position
what happened in just a few more moves
though after rook t1 e v it seemed like
Geoffrey just fell for an elementary
tactic I mean just getting Forks the
pawn is attacking both the Queen and the
bishop what do you make of this position
Catarina I mean you may think that he
fought for easier tactics but I think
that's the last thing we should consider
him knowing that he's such a strong
player I mean when you look at this
position you see rooks who are like on
the best files that they can possibly be
they are really strong they're attacking
the center this is just a great position
for white and if the pawn on d5 will
fell and probably what we'll get the
pawn I mean the light square bishop will
be also great and black pieces rook on a
a token f8 Queen on d8 I mean they're
all on the last rank it would be very
difficult to coordinate them yeah I mean
but we have to see white is losing a
piece and let's go forward to the
current position after Knight takes e5 f
take a five
Queen take a five black has an extra
minor piece here but it's losing a lot
of pawns it's three pawns plus the b7
pawn I mean it could be four pawns for
for a knight so that's what happened
Queen takes d5 King h8 AHA let's go back
to that position let's get the current
position on the board Queen take g5 was
so it's already three pawns for a piece
b7 pawn is kind of weak and can fell and
then the C pawn can run for a queen so
it's very tricky to to know what to do
about that with oh this is incredibly
imbalanced I mean I think it's easier to
play for whites when you have the pawns
because the intuitive plan is just to
capture pawns and push pawns and try and
make a queen
meanwhile plac probably has to figure
out how to coordinate the minor pieces
and usually in chess a minor piece in
the middle game is more valuable than
three pawns
but if whites pawns get rolling
especially on the Queen side it can be
it can be a bit scary for black so I
would have to pick Geoffrey in this game
I like his I like the dynamics
raishin and he's he's created and let's
try can be something like queen g6 try
to develop the rooks maybe some tricks
on the King like taking on h3 but my
pick would be white as well I think it's
difficult to play this with black pieces
certainly and we'll have to keep an eye
on this game I mean the players are
about level on time with with 20 minutes
per side and they're only on move 23
which means they have still 17 moves to
make in 20 minutes to get to move 40 to
get that extra time so we'll definitely
have to come back to this game pretty
soon because they'll probably be in time
trouble within maybe 10 to 15 more
minutes so let's look at Alejandro's
game the key matchup for the B group for
sure and with with Josh Frieda against
Alejandra Ramirez we have a more
positional battle let's just go back
quickly to see how this position
occurred we'll start from the opening it
was it was another Slav but this time it
wasn't an exchange Slav Josh Fidel may
be chosen more more fighting variation
with Queen c2 and then Alejandro plays
this move g6 which is a somewhat
alternative way of playing the the Slav
I think the player most notable for
playing this sort of structure is gotta
calm Sookie who very much enjoys putting
the bishop on g7 a very solid structure
and Josh wasted no time going for the
eccentric expansion with E for very
thematic move but we don't see this too
often so early on in these queen pawn
openings in this case because white
developed early with Queen c2 and Knight
c3 c4 does become possible so let's go
forward to the middle game position both
sides develop Bishop f5 was played which
looks like a nasty pin but free
delegates out of it very simply with
Knight take f6 Bishop take f6 and Queen
b3 and we can see maybe some slight
advantage for whites
I mean to - nice pawns giving white a
bit more space and also maybe some
target on d7 as well
so going forward Queen c7 h3 so maybe
some slow play and then Alejandra
thrusts forward with this move b5 and
whites in the situation now where it's
maybe not entirely clear how to deal
with upon tension normally in chess if
your opponent executes the pawn break
you have three options you can either
take the pawn you can push your pawn or
you can do something else in this case
Josh Goodell chose to do something else
with Bishop h6 after rook F c8 he played
somewhat a somewhat of a controversial
move here at c5 and justice doe Furyk
for a second we also have a result in
this section where Ali Morandi won
against Vladimir bellows did you want to
go to that game first to see what
happens yeah that actually finished
unexpectedly we can we can hop over to
this game and then come back to the free
Dell game it ended with a very
unexpected tactical blunder Ali mirandy
was actually in our in the studio space
before the broadcast and he was showing
this game on the board let's go back to
the position maybe from from here where
where black was under serious pressure I
mean the King was in the center the
center is wide open White had ideas with
Queen eight for a check and white played
a very strong move Bishop f4 which is
actually a pretty brilliant resource
even though the bishop is not defended
if Queen take f4 white could play this
intermediate Queen a for a check and
then after I move like 97 Black is
pretty much lost here so so Ali Mehran
do you had to fight his way back and
play a bit passively he played the move
Queen c8 and after 95 Black was finally
able to castle but white still had a lot
of pressure
rook a seven player I just want to
mention it's really great to see
starting with the Bishop f4 how white is
really trying to develop all of the
pieces like the bishop on c1 when we
move it back we see that it's the last
piece in the white scam that didn't make
a move I mean there's also Queen but at
least that is developed so Bishop c4 is
a great move like developing the bishop
and then when you see them be sure
moves then the knight moves to the
center and that we have we have an under
bishop on each other it's not doing
anything anymore so we move it to a
three so we see how these Grand Master's
just help and work with their pieces to
really find the best spot and develop
them actually that's one of the big
differences I see between Grand Master's
and amateur players is just how they
treat their pieces Grand Master's take a
lot of care in finding the absolute best
squares for their pieces while amateur
player is sometimes are careless
sometimes choose bad squares for for
their pieces so that's one of the best
ways to improve in chess is to actually
see how grandmasters coordinate their
pieces and and work together to pressure
the opponent's absolutely and also
grandmasters don't have like a favorite
piece I see it with weaker players they
often have like oh I really like this
Bishop and they care about it and then
the knight on in the corner is of no
concern for them so it's really
important to treat all pieces similarly
and care about their development that's
right and let's go for it the the
tactical moment in which ballast just
completely collapsed after Bishop e7 a
lemur and II was saying earlier that
white should play rook rook c1 to
prepare the c5 move but Palace chose to
play c5 right away which already looks a
bit suspicious because black has three
pieces attacking c5 and white only has
one defender and a lemur and II found a
pretty pretty nice resource here to play
pong e5 in which he's attempting to
distract the knight on d3 and simply
liquidate the position and then I
believe the the losing move from from
White was Queen to e3 and after Bishop
takes c5 Knight takes e5 e take f4
White's just losing a piece the kinds of
facts the knight is hanging nothing to
do this is an easy tactic but I can I
think it can also happen the way that
after a 5 y just didn't want to make a
draw because if you just take the pawn
on e5 midnight everything exchanges it
looks like it's gonna be a draw position
and sometimes when we want to avoid draw
no matter what I mean this is the
drawback we can fall into some easy
traps that's right and we do have
another result in group a between yarrow
zero book and Benjamin Bach the position
apparently ended in a draw
except I see the the board on screen
there and I mean this does not look like
a Josh position Oh looks incredibly
crazy I don't know what happens here if
we go back a few moves
it wasn't even repetition so what
happened White had a I had this huge
pawn expansion on the Kings side black
was going for play on the Queen side if
we go forward here e5 was played pretty
explosive move trying to open up the
diagonal for the Queen and the bishop 94
was played with the counter-attack Queen
b3 check the Queen's got traded and now
I see after Knight c3 I mean the
position looks crazy but they probably
agreed to a draw here based on the line
where white can very simply take on c3
and after the trade take take it's an
obstacle like Bishop ending yeah that's
what I think they saw I mean you
exchanged that now something like Bishop
d4 maybe rook takes c6 the Pont right
and I mean we have opposite colored
bishops there's just no way to break in
that's right and that's that's kind of
the tendency without court bishops and
in such endgame positions is they tend
to lead to very draw positions
especially if things get traded off so
so let's learn a game of Friedman Daniel
against if I see a divinely I think that
was a really interesting game starting
from the beginning that's right and this
was one that we were taking a close look
at earlier just because the position
from the opening was very sharp it came
from a goon felled line which I assume
is is pretty theoretical black chose to
employ this double feeding cattle up
with both bishops having potential for
for the position opening up
and I think the critical moments came
when black played Bishop take f3 where
the Queen is tied down to the bishop on
d2 meaning if Queen take f3 very simply
Queen take d2 and black would be up
apiece so why play pawn take f3 and then
we got a very imbalanced position where
white white has very damaged pawn
structure on the Kings side but but
White has a bishop pair so somewhat
imbalanced
perhaps chancellors for both sides a lot
has happened since then let's go forward
I know black went first and Queen side
play or first some some King side play
and Queen see it was a nice move making
use of the geometry across the board
hitting both the bishop on c4 the pawn
and h3 so black one the pawn and let's
stop it here before 96 and maybe you can
think about what white can do now the
Queen is kind of attacking the White
King there are no debts and pieces but
white wants to think how to protect the
King and what you do and I think Daniel
found a really nice maneuver here yeah
this move Bishop e7 it's I mean at first
it looks like a tactical move but it's
also positional move because the bishop
can in many cases help defend along the
long diagonal and in some cases y could
play f4 and the bishop could drop back
to G - absolutely so let's say if black
plays here 90 X before we can play
simply a foreign get the bishop back
King is safe I think what is totally
totally great in this position and black
can had some trouble but it was his play
just amazing move like I did not expect
it very strange move rook c8 leaving the
rook hanging but defending the the
knight on c6 and white made the decision
that this bishop is more valuable than
the rook and he chose not to take it I
think for a good reason because of the
bishop can be a very big asset later on
in the game white shows a more defensive
option with Queen f1 and black of course
does not want to trade Queens here the
rule in chess when you're debating
whether to trade Queens you always have
to think about King safety in this case
White's King is far less safe so blacks
should avoid the Queen trade of a thief
made the right decision playing Queen H
5 and the
continued let's zoom forward to the the
current position Knight f3 Bishop take
f3 Queen take f3 lots of moves have been
played black still avoiding the Queen
trade trying to open up the position
further trying to get more pieces into
play I do have to pause after rook take
b5 the rook appears to be hanging but if
we know this the rook on b1 is a bit
over works because it's defending the
rook on d1 which is being attacked by
the Queen so some very nice tactics here
from from the Seif so white did not take
on d5 white played a4 and some some more
trades and after the dust settles it
looks like black is up a clean pawn and
of course once they can still keep
Queens on the board a 6 played let's
zoom forward even more I mean this looks
very very problematic for whites Bishop
he won such a depressing swerve of the
bishop I mean we could have mentioned
that Vasa is our former teammate from
Webster University so we know that he's
very strong player a very active player
so moves like rogue a c8 I mean that's
that's what his arsenal is he can really
find this tactical strong moves that's
right and I wouldn't be surprised if
most of the opening is as based on some
sort of opening preparation I mean
hopefully we'll be able to get him down
for an interview later on assuming this
game doesn't go much longer because I
mean if we look at the position there's
ideas of rook t1 and White's pawn
structure is just so so unfortunate I'm
thinking maybe Bach should start with
just a very stabilizing move like h5
create some loot for the King and then
bring the rook in and I'm I would bet
that a lot of money on on the Cephas
yeah this is a type of the position that
can take two more hours to be played but
what black has advantage that is very
hard to lose so he will just try try
until white is gonna be tired and make a
mistake but we have another very
interesting game ended against a Cobian
so let's look at it wow this is this is
insane I was looking at this position
much earlier from the opening and
started as some kind of standard
nimzo-indian I would like to go back and
just look at the opening briefly in this
game because it does bring back some
nostalgia for me nimzo-indian is one of
my favorite openings as black to play
against d4 starts with the move Bishop
b4 and they actually went into one of
the very first lines I learned in the
nihms oh where black black essentially
develops all the pieces pretty
harmoniously with with the early 94 and
then plays f5 and when I first learned
this line I was I was very intrigued
because black has a slightly unusual
setup with the pawn structure playing
this early f5 controlling the e4 square
with with a lot of the pieces and I
actually learned a very funny line many
years ago where it starts off white can
play this move Queen c2 and it's a huge
fight for the e4 square black would then
take on c3 take on c3 92 oh sorry blacks
move castle and 92 and it looks like
white is just trying to put everything
on on the e4 square trying to remove the
knight and then black has a very strong
move Queen h4 supporting e4 and I'm
showing this just because the the next
move is is very aesthetic after g3 Black
has a very unexpected in 95 have you
seen this before I've seen this I think
actually showed me yes Wow okay I mean
it's it's it has to be at least a year
since I've I've actually seen this seen
this played and the idea being that
after plant a queen black is very happy
to deliver checkmate so the white King
this is excellent example of seeing how
the bishop on b7 it's really far away
but it's very strong the diagonal is
wide open and this is just perfect way
for black to to attack the king and also
the knight on e4 as Eric mentioned that
gonna be even in the game you will see
how important that square is and how
white want to defend that square that's
right the night away so we should
actually go back and see what happened
yeah as white shows a different idea 92
which which looks a little strange
because it's actually removing a piece
from controlling the e4 square but the
idea is to leave the bishop it
awkward on before the bishop is just
staring into a blank space it can't
trade itself off for the night and maybe
a move like a three is coming so let's
go forward Bishop d6 so maybe improving
the bishop and then ninety-two and if we
see the whites idea was to play f3 and
now I think White has succeeded in the
Battle of controlling the e4 square and
then from this position both sides may
be completed developments will go go
much more forward to the current
position we see this slightly unusual
Knight be one to a3 with the idea of
Knight d5 bit unexpected but I mean this
goes back to the whole idea that
grandmasters are they're always looking
for the best birth for their pieces so I
think in this position the Alexander njh
probably realized Knight is not doing
anything on d2 he envisioned it being on
a much more effective square like b5
absolutely and even if it takes more
moves to move the knight it's really
worth it because the night only to just
cannot do anything so that's really
important to see how we can transfer the
pieces to better squares that's right
and black very simply played a6 which
which takes away the b5 for the Knights
but the night has another maneuver to
come to c2 and the game progressed
bishops got traded keep going here to
the current position Queen III e 5 and G
4 and the position just seems to be
exploding black has a lot of pressure on
the Kings side but it looks like white
might be trying to orchestrate some King
side attack as well but again look at
the bishop on b7 I mean that's that's a
really weapon that's a real weapon
against the King on h1 now the game
continued context e4 and pawn takes g4
and yeah here we have the current
position where I mean black is trying to
perhaps create some more open lines on
it on the Kings side but I mean I really
like the the harmony for black in this
position the bishop aligned with the
Queen are aligned with the king and the
rook aligned with the Queen it's usually
a very good idea if you can put your
lesser valuable valuable pieces aligned
with your opponent's more valuable
pieces it can lead to a lot more
tactical
I am wondering here what if we do
something like nine g6 to f4 let's
exercising the night on h5 just an order
for tickets I take the bisshop I'll take
it then I play E for wow you for trying
to open up all the lines yes like the
room is probably you have still Queen
III and I cannot unfortunately take on
f3 or can i this year this rook is
undefended on Yeats
and I go back to Ruge f8 because I I
also have a thread that I can take on a2
and then take the rook on f1 I think
white has a very strong move in this
position clearly black wants to open up
both F file and the diagonal but I think
white kid just kill all of box fun with
the very simple f4 and I don't think
this line is too impressive for black
I actually amend taking one of three oh
you want to take on entry Oh sacrifice
of rook well it's too much just see I
have a friend in high school his main
slogan was sacrificed everything it
might be mate and he won a lot of games
but he also lost a lot of games so I
don't know if it's the best strategies I
had my own Club who who once told us hit
that he played a really good game and he
sacrifice a queen and sacrifice a rogue
and then he sacrificed a night it was
really cool and then I asked so how did
you play and he was oh I lost I was like
okay well well there's a distinction
between a sacrifice and a blunder like
if you if you sacrifice and you lose
it's a blunder but if you sacrifice no
and you win it's a sacrifice so let's
see if I go rook f8 instead of King
itself oh you want to play rook f8 it's
probably things attacked yeah what if I
just take the yeah I think that's the
only thing you can do but I think with
King mm-hmm
and now the pawn f3 is actually very
strong because there are some g2 threats
with checkmates
the knight on c2 is kind of off I have
bad news for you in this position your
your best piece on b7 is about to be
your horse piece
d5 I mean probably I have to but
it's not what I wanted to do yeah White
has a bit too much this is too much but
there are some ideas like this that
really just exposing the king with some
sacrifices can be a possibility yeah we
have so this is currently the position
I'm sure black is perhaps pondering all
all of these potential sacrifices it's a
very rich position and it's only the
first day there there's some there's
some pretty exciting games that we'll
have to keep our eyes on yeah so let's
look at another game from the from the B
tournament no we also have a list out
there where Grandmaster are Kesari
Andrew with androids the bakken mm-hmm
another draw so so far we have two draws
in one decisive game the current
position what's incredibly dry let's
zoom through this game let's see if
there is any excitement we have a
catalog I think we had a few Catalans in
the games today the opening was exciting
but I don't know if we want to spend too
much time on this game let's keep going
here sometimes with these Kyle on
positions the center can explode and
then we're left with very symmetrical
pawn structure it seems like that's what
happened in this game just a lot of
trades and after all the simplifications
it's just equal material and really no
side having one advantage so I don't
think we're gonna have to spend too much
time on on that game yeah and we have
some supporters of camel Dragoon from
the chat so let's see how camel Dragoon
is playing with Daenerys and o Kesava
Daenerys so that's group B and we have a
slightly unusual position did white ever
castle in this game my guess would be no
you guys still on eyi rook is on g1
let's zoom through don't wanted to give
too much emphasis on the opening but if
we just look at White's King so white
played the early rook g1 being provoked
by the bishop
we should mention castling would not be
illegal move it it would also just be a
bad move but the bishop does control f1
so rook g1 was forced
and Queen c7 with a counter-attack some
complications here why chose to play
Knight G for some simplifications there
is one factor in this position which
pops out right away
do you have any guesses to what that
might be that's opposite colored bishops
exactly I think that's a really
important part of the game right which
we saw before in the other game yes and
the room is usually who at hands has an
advantage because the squares are not
defended by the other bishop but it is
not clear if I can really take advantage
of this here because any time the bishop
can be on f4 the squares can be defended
by the pawns now Eric is somewhere else
in the position let's see that's right I
mean this is this looks like the current
position let's see if we have any
updates
we have rook ghs played I mean if I had
to predict the result I would think it
should be a draw but you can never know
if Queens on the board sometimes both
sides can have some potential attacking
chances and the pawn structure is so
weird that I wouldn't be surprised if if
one of the players could perhaps slip up
we should also note that black appears
to be in severe time pressure only
having less than three minutes on the
clock
yes and that can be a big difficulty
especially when sometimes you have to be
figuring out what is the exact proper
move here that you don't have this time
now one thing I want to note we are not
using any engines here so I would
recommend for you to do the same and
really try to understand it yourself
without any engine help because the help
can be very often inaccurate without you
understanding the position so just
wanting to throw it out there that's
true unfortunately we don't have a
Maurice we can go to for the engine
analysis so all of the commentary will
be our own thoughts and I mean we're
trying to be instructive and we are
keeping an eye on the YouTube chats so
shout out to everyone watching around
the world if you guys have questions or
or anyone who you're rooting for make
yourself heard let's move on I do want
to go back to the thief what did he
start with TF Ebrahim Ian's game begins
her game at Cinco I think she has a very
nice pose
I mean at the beginning we said every
time the first first first game is very
difficult for grandmasters or even the
weaker players in the field to play
because we are just starting off you
don't know who you are playing how it's
determined gonna turn out so anything
can happen in the first round and I feel
that I've has a more comfortable
position here yeah I mean we see another
obstacle efficient position this is well
it's a senior for the first round third
games so far off the Clara bishops the
Queen's are on the board and we should
immediately point out the time situation
Tata has less than four minutes a very
well defended pawn on a5 and I will say
Queens are not usually the happiest
types of pieces to blockade pawns which
looks a little bit uncomfortable for
lack given that the Queen might have to
stand that the the Queen site for a long
time keeping an eye on the a pawn but it
is blacks move Sergei is thinking in
this position I wouldn't be surprised if
white tries to orchestrate some kind of
King side attack given that blacks two
major pieces are far off on the Queen
side so perhaps a move like Queen c7
maybe some potential pawn storm
perhaps rook e1 these are all potential
ideas for a white to try and intuitive
on your pressure yes I think this is a
very interesting game now certainly
played rook e8 and that's a I mean
that's a move that he has to has to make
because otherwise if white could go rook
e1 then that could create some
difficulties on the seventh right that's
true I like to tell my younger students
rooks on open files have smiles and in
this position a file is one of the only
open files it's a good square for the
rook prevents any sort of counter play
from White's
if white wants to play rook e1 it
probably leads to two more drawing
chances for black yes any exchange that
is done here if they're the opposite
colored bishops left I mean that's a
draw that's nothing to do so we need to
try to attack but now it may be a little
difficult with the room being an open
file
that's right so let's move on to a
different game sure which one we haven't
seen yet or let's let's move on to the
German a for example Sam Savion against
prahasta
Peter what is happening there we haven't
looked at that we weren't looking at
this game before the broadcast started
and this was a game that I wanted to try
and avoid as much as possible because it
came from a berlin opening which is at
least in my opinion one of the more
boring openings and chests it's a very
strategic o in a diplomatic way a
strategical positional it was a great
choice for Vladimir Kramnik against the
very aggressive Gary Kasparov and I
think it was a good choice from Peter
against Sam Sevilla and kasam is known
to be kind of a tactical genius and I
think it's probably a great strategy to
steer the game and more positional
waters I absolutely agree and here in
this theorem and we will see you know a
lot of practice playing the trendy games
trendy lines but the players will also
try to be tricky and play openings that
are not comfortable for their opponents
so now when we think about Sam 7 being
an active and tactical player of course
Peter Prohaska will try to to defend it
a different way I mean to attack a
different way by playing openings that
maybe do not suit him and play something
that's more strategical that's right
what do you think about this position I
mean White has built up a pretty
impressive coordination of the pieces I
mean this come menacing-looking pawn
structure on the Kings side black seems
to be incredibly passive but the
parallel bishop can be tricky I mean any
time there will be c5 Bishop c6 the the
pieces can develop and another point to
make is how do you want to proceed like
do you want to do h4 h5 at one moment I
am not sure if it's that easy for you to
to do that yeah that is a good point
about the especially the bishop here in
general sometimes short-term bishops
might not be impressive but if you hold
on to them long term and the position
opens up they can be very very very
dangerous in this position there's still
kind of kept at bay Bishop on e8 just a
very depressed piece and the bishop on
e7 not that
impressive but it is a good question
what is White's plan here
not sure if white has any any immediate
threats but maybe it's just to improve
like start pushing pawns maybe improve
the King and I wouldn't be surprised if
if Sam can maybe try and grind this out
for a win
yes so he just actually took the rookin
d3 aha so the trader looks which can be
an interesting idea because Blake really
wants to play c5 and Bishop c6 but with
the rook being stuck on b8 the c7 can be
an issue because the King can be in
checkmate when we move the King to b8
then we can develop the bishop and then
the a6 one can be a weakness I'm not
sure I think it is it is okay for black
this position yeah as long as you can
kind of defend your weaknesses and not
allow too much progress to be made but I
think it's a lot more fun for white to
play in this position Samus uh appears
to be thinking here oh no he moved he
played rook take t3 so keeping the rook
on the open file and just to demonstrate
your idea if black plays immediate c5 it
could just walk into ninety five which
could spell a lot of trouble for black
given that the ninety takes you seven
would be a made threats mhm and Bishop
d8 appears to be the only move and then
maybe Y could play a six and this looks
pretty devastating now what if we go for
the game of the day between Josh Vidal
against Alejandro Ramirez
so moving yeah we were taking a look at
what happened earlier let's take a look
at the current position we have Queen
rook and Knight for both sides equal
material it's a little bit imbalance
because white pads these overextended
pawns on e5 and c5 and whenever you have
pawns extended far down the board they
can either be strengths or weaknesses
and in this case I would have to argue
that these pawns are more weakened than
they are strong what do you think about
this position I agree I think these
pawns are are weak especially because
they cannot move they don't
there you know any friends nearby how I
always used to say it to defend them or
help them to to advance now I lost the
position here well we have it on this
board it is this black smooth white just
played rook takes Bishop on e4 and I
would imagine Alejandra is probably
considering something like rook t5 or
rook t1 and just try and increase
pressure sometimes you you won't be able
to win something right away but if you
can optimize your pieces and really put
the pressure on yeah and we can look at
the rooks and a nice I mean the black
rook is operating on the file he's doing
great the white robe is kind of being
stuck on the file the knight only six is
attacking c5 pawn the night of free is
passive and we can clearly see that the
blacks pieces black pieces are
coordinated better but there are not
many pieces left on the board so that
can be an issue for for black to try to
take bigger advantage of this that's
right we should move on to the vas if
Terra Bailey game because that was
exciting earlier and I'm just trying to
find that there's a lot of games to go
through here no there is a huge time
advantage passive has one hour and his
opponent has only thirty minutes but
they did make time control so at least
at least Freedman is not in danger of
losing on time but we can see he took a
lot of time earlier Queens have been
traded Queen r3 was played oh there is
amazing trick I think white is in
serious trouble because now White has to
move route back on the e-file to be
defending the bishop but then I have
amazing threat with Bishop before so if
you move let's say rookie three I have
bishop before and you cannot capture the
bishop g1 is a queen yeah the person is
pinned to the g1 square that's a nice
tactic so if you so you can try to do
something like rook e8 to pin the bishop
so rook e8 instead of rookie three yes
exactly to try to pin the bishop but I
can go just king of recently king of
seven the rook is tied down
this could be over for for whites very
soon because I five is a threat black is
keeping the initiative I mean if we go
back just before qgq it's a real nice to
see these tactics how it unfolds because
the positions position looks very normal
yeah if white you just have a couple
moves take on g2 and and hold things
together but that's the power of the
initiative and that's also the power of
having a pawn very far down the board
there is sometimes more unusual tactics
which exists which involve pawn
promotion and we see that in this case
where where the bishop is just pins of
the square so black plate I mean white
plate rookie six in the game this is
what happened so why does trying to get
as many pieces as possible for the for a
piece that he's gonna lose so he's
giving up the bishop but he has a pawn
and the King site is two on two what do
you think Eric about this so I think we
can safely say that this position will
happen
I see it's already being played out
after rook take a1 and King take g2 this
is a current position I think it's just
an easy win for black especially with
this pawn being fixed on the dark square
that's what we can look you for port on
f2 is dark square pawn on f4 is dark
square we are just gonna take them
sooner or later
absolutely let's move on to what game I
like the game between
the active verrico biana gets in ditch
bar being black that's right this was an
idle gain which which seemed to be
exploding earlier but the position is
closed down if we go back to where we
left off after a g4 it appeared that
black was maybe considering some
sacrifice but chose probably a safer
move Knight HF for also the most natural
move why play d5 actually that's
something that white had to do what he
had to block the bishop from being
attacked from attacking the King and
finally you know feeling some safety for
for the white king
yeah and that's like a really important
strategy when you're being attacked you
want to close down the position as much
as possible in this case black was
trying to create more open lines
especially along the e-file and along
the diagonal I really like this move d5
because it closes both lines
simultaneously if we go forward that the
pieces on d3 got traded black still has
some pressure I probably would still
prefer black given this f4 square looks
very juicy for a knight though he chose
night-night h4 which goes after the f3
pawn 91 g6 I always thought it like will
want to play something like b5 to try to
attack the pawn chain and make some
weaknesses and maybe bring the bishop
back but it's very difficult to do the
to do it soon because still even if we
trade on c4 there is just not much the
piece is to attack the c-4 square and
sometimes you have to like identify what
area of the board that you want to apply
on
I think this holds true for a lot of
different types of positions you have to
identify do you play on the Kings side
you claim the Queen side you play in the
center I think the main focus for black
is to play on the Kings side so maybe
that's why he's holding off on the move
like b5 and he chose maybe the more
positional Bishop to c8 and so he
decided that the bishop is kind of done
on the diagonal h8 to I I mean a a to h1
and he's trying to move the bishop
somewhere else that's right and even
though the bishop doesn't look too
effective on c8 currently he might be
fathoming some ideas of some potential
h5 later for example if he can play g6
and h5
just trying to create more open lines
for the pieces we can also envision the
very straightforward Queen to f7 where
black would just have a massive battery
on the F file and we call this
Alekhine's gun or you have both rooks
and the Queen along one open file in
this case one half open file and there
could be some some trouble for white
here I mean the position looks
relatively passive we have a few more
moves here white played rook a to and
black played rook to f4 and I believe
this is a current position where okay
the rook looks very nicely placed maybe
considering some room T for ideas and I
mean this just looks a lot more fun for
for VAR black so any other games to move
on to and kind of scrolling through here
we should note to the viewers that you
can view all the games on u.s. chess
champs calm and then see the two
sections the games are being broadcast
live via chess 24 so feel free to to
take a look yourself and I mean there's
there's so much high-level chests to
cover so feel free to ask questions or
comment we will try to answer any
questions that you did you give us
that's right I do want to go back to the
Daenerys I do a cassava game against
Camille dragon because the positions of
kind of heating up where black is going
for this very feisty pawn break with h4
trying to maybe destabilize the Kings
side and we can imagine that black might
be considering some future f4 as well
where this Bishop could be short on
squares I really like the way Jinora is
playing I mean she's being resourceful
with the pieces she has and in this case
with with Kings on opposite sides black
really wants to make an effort to to
open up the King side absolutely and you
also see that the pawn on h5 is a huge
weakness so we want to get rid of it and
when we open the H file get the room
there as well that's gonna be
option that's true and I think from
lacks perspective in this position
because black has have the focus on the
kingside it's it's important for black
to keep material on the board you don't
want to trade
rooks or Queens without any reason
and if black can keep the pressure I
wouldn't be so thrilled as white but we
should note the time situation dinara
has less than two minutes with her time
ticking down but also widest point out
that's true I'm still happy with white
because because there's no threat are
can you save our position is safe
oh we have a game that is older so let's
see whatever we see the Cecil se
outside against Daniel Freedman on
screen
I see the bishop yeah anyone this would
be predicted that's great
you show up up so let's see just a game
so what's finished and I am being sure
that we will have the seat for an
interview so as soon as he can come down
I'm very curious to ask him about kind
of the opening preparation in this game
and see how much was preparation how
much was kind of over the board play I
am looking for the final position here
just to see how the game concluded ooh
finishes it's very unfortunate for a
white the thread the fish of h2 pretty
much unstoppable getting the pawn on f4
not only is black winning a pawn here it
looks like some kind of mating net let's
say white pushes upon Bishop h2 King h3
Bishop take f4 may it would be pretty
much unstoppable game over
yes you could even try some of your
tricks to to maybe go first King somehow
to force g5 but I don't see how to do it
and try some stalemate oh yeah that's
here especially I love the still matrix
but I think like a thief would be too
good to fall for any of that so very
nice finish
so as we're waiting for a thief to get
in the the the commentary room let's
look at the game of Sam Savion against
Peter Prohaska I think that's the really
interesting game with the two bishops
and how black is kind of developing them
or not wait or not develop a future here
with the bishop on e8 going to d7 c8 and
the a6 Paul I do want to mention that
can be a weakness I see what you mean
yeah the for extended pawn on e6 doesn't
have any defenders it does take a long
time to attack that pawn though but how
do you want to stop it that is a point
so you're saying that could maybe go for
something like row ta trade rooks and
then Bishop d7 Bishop seems well it's
White's move here both players are in
fine pressure and they still have what
12 moves to make before time control but
I think this is a great position to see
how the bishops even if they are on the
background can be strong and because
they have the future now white played c6
in the position yeahi six could be could
be a very thematic move going for the
past pawn and you want to think about
your bishop on f2 which is not developed
it doesn't do anything and getting into
G's g3 and the diagonal they're
attacking looking that's that's a future
that's right well we're gonna keep a
close eye on this game but we're going
to break and we'll be back with receive
Dara Bailey this is a crucial situation
in this game Matheny must make a move
but what will it be all eyes are on the
theme to make a move a lot easier if you
weren't doing that right next to me
it doesn't bother me check the st. Louis
chess club celebrating 10 years of
promoting teaching and playing the game
of chess visit the st. Louis chess club
and help celebrate our 10th anniversary
[Music]
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chest 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chest
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
from the best and even challenge them to
a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with just 24 premium membership
hello and welcome back to the Summer
Classic I am international master Eric
Rosen here with Grandmaster massif Tara
Bailey and congratulations Wasif you
have a very nice win today thank you
very much so I do want to ask about your
opening preparation it seemed like a
theoretical line and ago so if you can
walk us through the opening actually I
did not expect him playing this line he
usually goes here g3 instead of 93 AHA
so I think I untied roof and usually but
so I wasn't really prepared against
Knight c3 but okay it's the main line
here I did not know Bishop d2 move I
knew that the main line is he takes d5
Knight d5 Bishop c4 so the idea of
Bishop d2 is to take C takes d5 95 for
and when I take Knight c3 you would have
bishops III move so I didn't want a role
in that
so I played knight c6
their idea is that if if white takes C
takes d5 95 d4 here I can take Knight c3
Bishop c3 and Bishop g4 so I think that
should be that looks nice it looks like
a kind of a dream Greenfeld setup where
you have a ton of pressure against a d4
pawn so that's why he played the h3 he
didn't want me to play Bishop g4 so I do
D takes e4 yeah let's go forward and see
where the position got got a bit spicier
because it seemed like things got very
complex after the sequence Knight a5
Bishop a6 and c5 in the position seemed
to explode I was expecting maybe we
should take B saw Andrew d1 might be 751
something like that but white doesn't
have anything so position should be
around equal but when you play D takes
e5 it was a little bit risky because
King gets weak so bishops that's right
they should take f3 how are you feeling
around this point after after Bishop
take a free G take up three I felt like
I had attack and and probably playing
with blacks would be easier certainly
seemed more fun to go for some some King
site play and now the other cat other
commentator Katarina was wondering about
this move a bit later where you played a
very unusual after Bishop e7 rook to see
it leaving the rook hanging were you
concerned that you might be just losing
material after Bishop takes the eights
no I mean I when I played it was my idea
to sacrifice exchange and attack sorry I
don't think that dr. Bishop see it why
it is better because we shall see it
through c8 now I want to play 95 so I
think white needs to play something like
f4 and here I wasn't sure what to choose
it black has several options like 'if
I've here
it's really interesting or just take
night before midnight before those fine
then I would have Knight g4 seems like a
position rich with ideas for black and
they'll be a lot less pleasant for a
while it was kind of positional
sacrifice long term for sure yeah vice
king is weak so that's why he played
Queen upon he didn't like disposition
yeah I was considering queen F on King F
on Luke c7 dr. Bishop c6 position I've
been I did not read the like I think
it's slightly better for white passport
we can create passport that's true it
should be equal so but after a queen h5
I told I had better chance at what point
did you feel like it was a turning point
where you really had a stable advantage
when he did not think wine exchange
eb-5 f4 9 f3 here I knew that my
position was much better and it is
really hard to play with white so of
course especially if when you keep
Queens on the board the king is never
safe with the the open pawn structure on
the Kings side and the conversion seemed
pretty smooth I mean the rest of the
game he blundered after Knight d5 would
be far but I don't know what else white
can play I mean yeah the pieces do not
look too impressive for white and I mean
it seemed like a simple tactic that may
be why overlooked but ok what else to do
yeah when your position is bad this is
really the snowball effect yeah so I was
expecting actually instead of Ruby one a
for maybe mm-hmm
a four-bar here also I was considering
if I've got such a thematic idea for the
green fell just open up more lines maybe
try and get the rook in this is really
hard
that's right to play for poor whites Oh
laughter out there will be long you 595
I do want to ask about the final tactic
I mean me and Katarina or were pretty
impressed with this this final pawn
promotion tactic how far in advance did
you see that or did it just come kind of
come about here I felt like I should
easily but I didn't see for a long time
how to win but when I aged far I played
I think Brooks if for was in a bad move
in this position yeah I was thinking
maybe he should have played group before
he said the Roxy for look before mm-hmm
so and what's the difference the
difference is that no I cannot really
play h4 because white would play rook b8
mm-hmm just go for in my game he didn't
have rook c8 because rook e1 when you
want and go back because oh I see so far
it's nice tactics here Mookie 1 and the
rook is undefended on c8 yes so just a
small detail something else can change a
lot of things between rook rook c4 to
see it in rugby for TV yeah after rule
before I wasn't really sure I was
thinking about taking he won and they go
into the the Queen ending yeah it was
gonna be a long like it would be a very
long fight from here is Asians are not
go see something I mean black children
somehow yeah sure but it's not easy I
agree so after h4 Queen for seemed like
the use of the H pawn really helped you
out and when you play Queen g2 you saw
that you saw the finish that's very nice
so now the bad start to the tournament
perfect score so far it's only only the
first day how are you feeling going
forward well I've been just totally to
say something with
see how next games are going do you know
who you play tomorrow I think English
I'm playing against English any thoughts
on that game well I think I haven't
played against him so I'm not familiar
with his style so I'm going to check
tonight very nice and I do want to ask
you too we are a former teammates at
Webster University I know you you you're
still a student there are you done with
the semester tomorrow I have my last
class and I have essay not actually a
research paper I need to finish it
tonight that's got to be really tough
balancing the chest preparation and the
research and tomorrow so I have Final at
night I don't know I think well I'll let
you go best of luck with your research
paper and with the the next games and
we'll take a quick break and we'll be
back with with more coverage thank you
very much
[Music]
for your family
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this August the best chess players in
the world are coming to st. Louis for
the grand chest tour st. Louis rapid and
blitz and Sinquefield Cup tournaments
will feature the world's best right here
in st. Louis
st. Louis chess club to celebrating its
10th anniversary and these tournaments
will be a highlight you won't want to
miss for tickets and more information go
to st. Louis chess club org
[Music]
welcome back through summer chess
classic I'm Katherine M koa
here with Eric Rosen and we have some
results for the round one so let's see
what happened yeah we have I believe
three games finished in each section in
Group A we have my mistake we only have
two games finished in this section we
have yarrow jariabek who drew against
Benjamin Bach and the sea star Bailey
defeating Daniel Friedman with three
games still pending
I think the the game still going some of
them are very exciting I know we were
taking a look at the the Sam Savion game
earlier and I think we should focus on
on this one just for a little bit
because the the rook endgame looks
incredibly instructive and it seems like
Sam is pushing for a win given given the
position of his rook his pawn his King
everything seems to be going in White's
favor but do you think white has enough
potential to actually convert the
advantage how many white is just on the
road with the king to h5 g6 and that can
be very hard to stop unless I can go
King d8 Kingi it can get 7 quickly
enough that's right and we should note
the black is probably debating between
the only two classical moves here either
King g7 or rook to e8 but I'm not sure
if these moves make much of a difference
given that White's plan is just so clear
I can curious how this happened because
I really like the bishops everything
good you did like great for break and
suddenly I feel like I'm losing so let's
go back to where the bishops were still
in existence so the e6 was I think the
last move if we went right and Bishop d6
so black was able to activate at least
the dark spread Bishop 94 logical Bishop
e5 do you can just go back for a second
after six do you agree with Bishop d6 I
thought our goal was to trade the rooks
with Droog the 8th now is there is a
tactical trap
somewhere rook t8 certainly looks
logical it might walk into Bishop g3 and
surprisingly enough this a7 pawn could
fall in the end after some line like
well then I try to show no you want to
be tricky with a four it's kind of a
[ __ ] line I mean the Bishop Bishop
needs to be rescued by the Knights but I
think white would be doing very well
here
and again these bishops not coming to
life so it seemed like Peter made a
logical decision trying to activate at
least one bishop because there's also
one interesting line that after Ruby ate
Bishop g3 so in this line rook to Bishop
g3 yes if I go now Bishop d6 there is a
seven mm-hmm d7 and now I can go Luke
takes d6 making use of something tactics
after maybe something after rut 86 of
rook being pinned and whenever there's a
pin piece you should attack the pins
piece don't take the 10 piece 94 which
is for whites so there are some issues
with Blake just wasn't fast enough to
develop although the position looked
okay okay so that happened 90 we should
be 694 so let's go there and yeah let's
get to the current position we do have a
move that was played King d7 will go
forward there's some dancing around with
a knight like going from b7 to d8 very
unusual output squares that you don't
see every day so we see the pawn on a6
is again we're against very strong right
because we have the current position
okay so V sandwich was obviously so the
problem for a black is a the King is
tied down to the c6 pawn so move like
King EA could walk into rook takes c6
and meanwhile what else is black doing I
mean that even if we exchange rooks or
something black has nothing on the Queen
side the double pawn does not allow to
create a free porn and
does the white ink on the kingside can
just win some advantage yeah I would
have to say it's over I mean we don't
have engine analysis to support it but I
mean we were we were admiring Peters
choice earlier on saying that the Berlin
is like a good choice against Sam but
Sam has proven that he can play some
positional some positional masterpiece
given given his play in this game I mean
this is just exactly what white wants
from from a Berlin opening is to get
this as past pawn with the kingside
majority I agree I think the game is
over
it was very nice play for Sam I think
Peter was was fine at some moment but
then it was as difficult to move with
the pieces around and then he got into
difficulties that's right we should move
on to another really exciting game
that's taking place between Alexander
and itch and version of Cobian position
has opened up if I'm counting material
it is equal but White's King looks very
suspicious I mean every time you see
Knight and queen around the King that's
a problem
this is like Bishop and queen right yes
I just by looking at the position I
think why this what is not doing very
good yeah I mean especially with Queens
on the board
White's last move was 92 where do you
think the the Queen should move in this
position I mean what if I can just what
if I stayed there with the Queen and
then just move the pawns like well the
crews attacked right hits I mean Queen B
- sorry what happened Oh Queen B - is
play that's C so now now white is the
one under pressure and yeah the strategy
for black is just to keep material on
the board especially keep Queens on the
board and and just keep keep the
pressure on white and we should note
that these Kings side pawns even though
they don't look too menacing right now
they are passed pawns and they could be
relevant later in the endgame
maybe we black doesn't want to start
pushing too early because they do
provide some shelter for the King the
good part for white is that they're they
passed the control they have 30 minutes
the time control is done that's true day
one so at least I can think about you
know how to coordinate his pieces and
survive this because if you have enough
time sometimes you can find the perfect
moves to just defend it yeah and even
though it's uncomfortable for Wyatt yeah
that's good point is if you have enough
time to play accurately it might not be
so bad but if the players get into time
trouble again this will be a lot more
unpleasant to play for a white given in
the position so we should definitely
keep an eye on this I'm sure given that
the players have reached the time
control that there will there will be
some long things any other games to look
at I mean we should maybe go back to the
game when you're doing solid right
Savion between peter Prohaska oh is that
game like king h5 and there's really
nothing that black can do against the
king attacking the pawns on the Kings
side it's beautiful
I mean I've after seeing this game I
might be inspired to try and play
against the Berlin from the white side
and not only just the the play in the
opening but kind of the the long-term
strategy for white really keeping
black's pieces restricted I think this
will be a very instructive game to show
to show my students yes I like this and
I'm curious what Sam is gonna say about
about the opening option that his
opponent chose if he felt comfortable or
not I hope you gonna get him to the
studio yeah I mean he just finished so
so it's possible
let's switch gears let's take a look at
the Geoffrey Jean game which we haven't
looked at too recently a lot has
happened the last time he looked at it
Geoffrey was winning all blacks pawns
but he was down at peace after we saw
this this ePHI move with the fork and
the material and balanced and it it
looked more pleasant for whites but
let's go to the the current position
where black still has the extra minor
piece northern f6 but white has three
pawns for the piece this pasty pawn
could be a bit dangerous still very
imbalanced it's going to be a
do you have a side that you would prefer
here I think the black knight on f6 is
very restricted it can't really go
anywhere so it's the piece is literally
useless and if we get as wide upon on g5
I think the pawns on the King sides
really defend the King well so I don't
think white is worried about the game
here so I think white is the one who is
playing for all I would probably agree
like that the king is safe enough g5 is
a weakness and sometimes when you have
too strong points or a strong point and
a weakness for the opponent that gives
you more more to play for in the
position where in this case because
White has a pasty pawn the the black
Queen might be a bit tied down and then
like can try and overwhelm black by by
trying to attack the g5 pawn as well
it's what we call the principle of
chewing this is in chess and it can be a
very powerful mechanism so a this box
move here Jumma by of is is taking
taking some time to figure out what to
do next
I must say it's not fun for black to
play because if there's really it
doesn't seem like there's any active
play so sometimes black just has to wait
and white might be having more fun yeah
I think this is similar to the vassals
game where he was you know pawn up and
just pushing pushing maybe playing for
one hour I mean the game finish finished
much much sooner because of the tactics
but it's a game where the weak side may
get tired after many many moves and I
think Geoffrey is just too too skilled
in these positions to yeah I mean it's
what we call playing for two results
where you have a comfortable advantage
you you don't want to risk too much but
you can play a long game try and provoke
some mistakes from your opponent and I
mean as we know as former former spice
students that's a very good strategy and
team chess where you don't want to take
too much too many risks but you want to
have these kind of long fights where you
can grind down your opponent so let's
look at the game in the B tournament the
key game of the day against Josh Fidel
against Alejandra
almost forgot about this game yeah and
now we have Josh Fidel who is a pawn up
in a night and game Josh is actually
down the pond it's a hundred playing for
a way I believe to on three on the Kings
side have you ever had this position
before I feel like this is common enough
where that maybe you've had this some
this type of position a similar position
I mean similar only that it was not in a
game and pawn up but the pond was on the
queenside and that's much easier to play
when you have a passed pawn especially
night and games because the pawn just
goes goes the knight has to defend it
and then you can focus on the King side
well in this position this pawn up may
not be such a huge advantage or maybe
difficult to to transfer it to a hall
win yeah I would say probably with
perfect player this position should be a
draw but I would expect Alejandro to try
and torture Josh in this position that
this could be a very very long fight and
it's all about trying to create the past
pawn to try and use a knight to control
the key squares to to prevent white from
simplifying in any way I've actually had
this the same ending as from the white
side where I was down upon and I had to
defend and it's not fun there's there's
going to be some torture in this game
and how did I manage to draw except my
opponent probably had some some chances
to win it wasn't the most precise game
from either side I forget my my opponent
happened probably four or five years ago
but I will say with long games like this
it can take a toll on your physical
energy and sometimes the strategy is at
least from the black side you want to
wear down your opponent physically so
you might provokes a mistake and some
later critical position yes and if you
look at the game between Camille Dragoon
and Daenerys adieu Kesava we have again
a position where white is this and white
is pawn up and it's it will be the same
long game opposite forward bishops but
like will have difficult time of
defending this
at Lee's death mile yeah that's another
kind of torture position where okay
white is playing for for two results
trying to grind down black and again
probably with perfect play it should be
a draw but in a practical scenario I
mean humans are not going to play
perfectly and especially White's
potential to make a pass pawn in the
Kings side with White's King already
being on the Kings side to help support
a passed pawn this doesn't look fun for
black to defend and I would probably
choose white playing for a win over
black playing for a draw I mean I think
that'll be an easy choice to do here but
what I want to say is these positions
are really they really show well how
grandmasters defame differ from normal
players or weaker players who can relay
grandmasters can very often defend this
with black pieces and that's a real
strength to be able to not lose a game
that looks much worse as an endgame
whereas if you play it against club
player or somebody who is much weaker he
can collapse immediately and you can win
an easy game but this can be a really
long fight that's true and we should
note though the one kind of upside for
black is that any sort of trade of rooks
should end in a draw so sometimes black
can use that to maybe threaten some
trades maybe go for some idea like
Bishop c6 to b5 and play rook c4 and and
use kind of this notion of theoretically
drawn endings to try and to try and
improve the position and and not let
White's get too much play but it's going
to be another one fight and a lot of
these games could go on a much much
longer so let's go back to engage
against a called young game it is very
nice our white try to exchange the
Queen's to get to get into safe position
blood but black declined and played
Queen b1
yeah I would have to say this is
probably the most exciting game out of
all the games left is that I mean the
the Queen's are still on the board
there's going to be some fire happening
the the White King very unsafe
I like this Queen B one move controlling
the first drink attacking the efore pawn
but I mean it's still not clear how
black is actually gonna win this
position yeah because the knight on g2
and e2 they are actually really good
they are defending the g1 square that
you want to Israel so it's not that easy
to you to go and attack the King but I
think move like h5 is gonna come sooner
or later
at some point black might have to resort
to pushing the pawns to try and apply
even more pressure I think we can assume
white will somehow defend the pawn maybe
a move like Queen III to do if you play
Queen III what if I do something like 90
g5 where I try to attack the pawn on e4
again and maybe transfer the Knight to
h3 do you know to push the King around
to see what's gonna happen it's very
possible idea yeah I was actually
looking at a bit more exotic move Knight
h2 okay this might be too exotic but
going for this f1 square it seems like
Black has a lot of potential with ideas
in the position not to mention that if
you want to be positional as black you
could just play the very safe Knights v5
the ideas of 93 and I think it's really
important to point out I know we
mentioned this earlier but the Queen
Knight combination is just so powerful
because the Queen the knight can
coordinate and ways that other pieces
just can't and especially when you're
attacking the King it's it's a tough
combination to defend against and also
when we look at the white palms they're
all on the white squares so if at some
moment the bishop gets to d1 I mean
that's a problem so you're thinking long
term yeah yeah because I mean you may
want to think let's say queenie 395 so
Queen e3 Knight g5 okay and let's say to
go something like okay you cannot go 93
because there is not h3 checkmate but
let's just show that just for the the
younger viewers that's a pretty pretty
aesthetic checkmate their queen the
knight the bishop all taking away
squares from the king
so there's the issue but with nice night
sir not very right I think there's like
it's interesting there's probably two
different ways black to try and win this
position one is by like trying to go for
the attack where you're going for some
mating attack against the king the other
way is going for a positional play where
if the Queen's do someday come off the
board
white spawn especially on be three or
four could be weak black has a passed
pawns so I think there there's many
different chances for for Verico bian to
come out on top in this game yes I think
var is absolutely the favorite here
because he can be trying and trying put
traps and traps and you have to remember
that white is playing already like two
hours or actually maybe three hours four
hours and then you get higher then you
make a mistake and var can immediately
take advantage of that because he's not
getting that tired when you are
defending you are it's more difficult
job than to attack so I think this is
this can be a really hard game for white
that's right and I mean we should
identify so the the games left are
verrico bian Alexander engines we have
Geoffrey Zhang against Rinat Juma bios
so let's look at the result so far yeah
we should take a look at what's
happening in the tournament three games
are done in the a group as we mentioned
before is Arabic Benjamin Bach ended in
a draw Samsa vien defeated Peter
Prohaska and a beautiful positional
masterpiece in the Berlin and we had
received our Bailey defeating Daniel
Friedman with the black pieces and I
should note at the GM level it's not
easy to win games as black so that's a
very good start for receive two games
still pending I'm looking forward to
seeing how the in Jacoby in game
finishes yeah bowl games are super
interesting and I think we will all
follow them but let's look for the
pairings for tomorrow for the second
round so we have Benjamin Bach playing
against three Najma buyer Kobe on with
Jeffrey Zhang that's gonna be really
interesting game especially when they
played already in a championship this
year then we have a safe against engage
passive robbery
Alexander ended parry Prohaska against
Daniel Friedman and yarrow cherubic
against Sam Savion now lots of exciting
matchups for tomorrow let's take a look
at the results for Group B so far and we
have two games still pending between
Camille dragon and Daenerys I do it
Sidhu a cassava and also the game of the
day Joshua JAL against Alejandro Mira's
and those could be very very long
flights none of the games that are still
pending are like boring or looking for a
draw that they can all be decisive
results not at all but we should we
should point out the only decisive game
in Group E so far is a lemur on D
vladimir Bella's game where it was just
determined by some some careless
boundaries so how does that start for
former on D yeah so let's look one of
pairings for tomorrow so tomorrow we
have a series of matchups we have dinara
against a lemur on D we have Andres to
copan against Bellis ramirez against a
Kesari on we have matt Senko against
Fidel and Camille dragon against Tata of
Abraham Ian so I think we're gonna cut
it short here if you want to follow the
games go to us chest champs calm and you
can see all the games in beautiful
format and we will be back at 1 p.m.
actually we'll be back at 3:30 p.m.
Central time tomorrow with the broadcast
the games will start at 1 p.m. in st.
Louis stay tuned and we'll see you guys
tomorrow
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you